and the person is watching this he knows
who he is some people are like flies you
know what flies do they land on poo
I have come together again with one
woman charity who I trust Abdullah who
had 100 donation policy we are now
raising funds to build houses for those
who have been homeless due to natural
disasters in Afghanistan Syria and
Pakistan please donate whatever you can
may Allah build you guys at home for
helping and enabling them to have a
house so I've done a post two days ago
of a funny video which you're going to
see probably my left on my right where
there's a couple of gorillas basically
and somebody's done it's not from this
from someone else that's what I found it
really Financial I was laughing and
those who have sense of humor would
laugh at it you know
um and it just showed that those who
pray leaving or it looks like sneaking
out or whatever it may be now personally
I myself follow the eraka the tarawi
like I believe eight you know I throw
eight not the 20. both are valid okay
that's fine you know the discussion is
not that hand I'm not going to kind of
make a unnecessary Fitness I just found
it genuinely funny and I didn't look at
the comment section I just posted I've
been really really busy with many things
and I left out now and I got a message
from us yesterday and he did seem a
little bit upset and I thought was
subhanallah I don't know what's going on
literally I had no idea what's going on
so I want to read the comment sections
and I realized there's a lot of people
laughing joking Etc there were some
individuals you know different reactions
there were some who like I'm unfollowing
you which I don't care you don't need to
follow me like I'll be honest with you I
don't care if he's following me not
follow me I I try to speak the hack
whatever it is or as long as I'm not
committing Haram so I don't care if you
want to follow me don't follow that's
not a problem I'm following me I don't
really care so then we had people who
were like oh Adidas a cafe or something
like that is mocking the dean or what's
wrong with eight raka I never thought to
myself ah okay it seems like it's been
misunderstood firstly I follow the
aulaka number one so I'm not walking the
people who do eight record I just saw
that video as me being an individual who
when they're playing in a Masjid and
promise green for example they do 20.
when I'm leaving I just try to get my
way out there you know because I need to
go because they're going to start
carrying on with the 20. I just saw it
as like I just want to say I'm really
funny but I did understand the necessary
that was coming from Tamia now how does
this relate to that
today's video is exactly about that
brother sisters taking Messiah because
all of us in one day shape or form or
one day in our life we're gonna have
Nasir from those who genuinely care and
abutemia are those two people who I see
there are sincere why because at the end
of the day there are two public figures
they could have easily go and nitpick or
do a video attacking me and guess what
they would get a lot of views they could
have easily come and do this in many
instances of certain stuff that I may
have done which they may have differed
and I believe me there are things I
differ with very clearly with him I have
you know I would say this response you
know this agreement is hearing they're
nothing major but the point is what the
following that both of them are see us I
take why and brothers and sisters you
need to put into category the
individuals that give you in the seal
there are those who are looking for a
downfall opportunistic individual
literally they are looking for your
mistake I mean so much so that I am
being told that this individual who I'm
talking about it has done another video
there's I think five or six videos just
there and it's been getting backlash
because of it and people you can see
very clearly for him now yeah it's just
basically somebody who's sitting on his
desk has zero experience in the tower
who is there criticizing everyone it's
not just me everybody Daniel how can
catch you you know you name it
everybody's on the list you gotta
sitting at home and nitpicking and then
there are those who genuinely care now
Daniel should message me about a video
that I did about the Queen's death he
messaged me and I thought to myself now
I don't really agree with that because
you're on this point but furthermore I
thought to myself let me look into this
I spoke to my teacher and my teacher
said you know what he has a point I took
the video down and here's a message from
Daniel I can show you very clearly that
he came with that concern I didn't say
you cannot give me in a CR I didn't say
how dare you I'm Ali the great yeah no
I'm only needs that one I took that
Messiah and I took the video down
because there was a concern where I was
like I can see where it's coming for
it's not like it was Haram or I said
something not according to the dean but
it could come across like that so I took
the video down the same with celebrity
Mia I just I'm doing this video just to
make it very categorically clear I
personally believe there is nothing
wrong with that video of the gorilla
it's a simple joke but seeing some
people in the comment section having
some issues and I thought it could bring
some behind and I don't want people
bickering and talking in Ramadan it
should not be a month of us doing that
so stand up routine message me and I
take his Messiah seriously because he's
somebody I believe who is genuine who's
not looking for my downfall who's not
nitpicking and seeing how can I catch
Ali dawa you know watch all my videos
and how can I catch him yeah okay and
he's a person I trust his knowledge yes
not everybody who goes to Medina
brothers and sisters become people who
have knowledge some of them have no
hikmah like all they know is text
memorized in their head they have no
wisdom and like I can call some of them
not all Muslims may Allah bless them
some of them are absolutely and
literally they think their view is the
only way so when you started message me
I said you know what Savannah I'm going
to take that down and by the way by the
time you watch this video down video I
would have took that video down on
Instagram why because it came from a
place of sincerity he could have gone
and do a video on publicly refuted me no
he chose to message me privately and
said you know what bro it came it comes
across like that problem
not once did anyone who knows me who
have my number went to the levels of
which I've heard apparently I'm being
accused of basically mocking the dean I
mean how giant can you be oh my gosh
Medina student apparently Madeira
students equating that with mocking the
dean Oster about nobody came to me and
said you're mocking the D they just said
it comes across as if the valid opinion
of the by the way yes for this Medina
student yeah there's a difference of
opinion oh there's different opinion
that eight o'clock it seems like as if
I'm not validating that opinion and I
was like you know what it can come
across like that I see that yeah not
mocking The Deen but seeing as if you're
not taking that opinion um as if it's
valid and I said 100 I agree and I'm
taking the video down it's as simple as
that guys I'll give you guys a quote and
I'll end on this inshallah inshallah um
said the following some people are like
fly and this person is watching this he
knows who he is some people are like
flies you know what flies do they land
on poo I'm gonna put poo they're on the
left hand idea some people are like
flies they don't see any good in people
they go and land on wounds and flies
where there's dirty places this shows
you that this type of people guys do not
want anything good for you they are
individuals who are looking for your
downfall how can they capitalize from
your name how could they just attack you
for no reason and alhamdulillah people
are seeing their true facing this
individual's true face alhamdulillah yes
and the Flies are like that as you can
see Roman sisters the fly goes and lands
on the pill because that's what it sees
and that's what it likes it doesn't know
anything else it just sees the bad in
people the negativity in people how to
just warn against people not seeing this
person has goodness no anything bad and
the one the prophet sallam said the one
who looks for the mistake of the people
Allah will find his fault in his very
household
exposing this individual but I want to
thank
you and those who are sincere in the
Nasir who are not opportunistic
individuals who are looking how can I
see the downfall of this individual may
Allah bless you guys for messaging me
giving me that Nasir and I take your
sincerity on board and I see where you
guys are coming from password
I took that video down of Queen
Elizabeth and with this video series
come in that not I'm mocking the dean
but it can come across as if it's not a
valid opinion alhamdulillah so that's
the reason why I will be taking down
that video that's all I wanted to say
guys and may Allah make us among those
and give us people friends that are
genuinely sincere and who care about us
rather than taking going public at every
opportunity to attack Duart who are
doing good works may Allah bless them
inshallah I disagree with that you will
never see me I've never seen that public
video refuting you know why because
number one I didn't see anything to
refute you number one number two if he's
good at least but I'm not going to be a
fly like certain individuals going and
Landing on poo and just seeing the bad
thing okay so I would let these
individuals carry on living in the Poo
but I'm going to inshallah assume the
best in the Believers and see the great
work they're doing may Allah rid this
disease in our heart in this Ramadan of
looking for the fault of others
inshallah